i'm here with jeffrey moore again in the
last video we talked about how writing
is kind of different things for
different folks you have writing as
expression that's for the writer and
then you have writing is something that
might inform you or entertain you as a
reader and there it's it's a product
something something you're looking at
and we talked about the a potential
process anyone there are multiple ways
of of tackling it for for the for the
writer but i guess how does a reader
look at the product or evaluate the
product this is an interesting situation
in particular
writing in the context of college
writing or what we often call the
freshman writing requirement
there's actually a very large body of
standards if you will
around what constitutes
good and effective writing in in an
academic context and and they carry over
actually quite well to a business
context
you can apply the model also to informal
and creative writing but it doesn't
apply as well so this is primarily think
about primarily in the context of essay
writing in that context there are three
traditions of value
that that the readers that readers seek
in in in a strong in an effective essay
the first is is logic
and then you actually make sense you
actually make sense and logic tends to
be about the world so basically what i'm
what i want logic to do is to
represent forces in the world and give
me a map for avoiding the bad ones or or
mitigating them in some way and
leveraging the good ones
and and and and when you're using
language in that context it's actually a
power tool and so you want you know like
you have saws and you have hammers and
you have stuff that you have nouns and
verbs and modifiers but basically
they're power tools and they're designed
to give you mastery over the world
that's what you want and so logic is
about you know are you in fact do i in
fact believe
the the um
the way you're representing the world in
fact corresponds to the world and and an
example of
i always like to use bad examples yeah
so an example of bad logic would be um
my my cat enjoys drinking milk therefore
i should be president of the united
states
that would be yeah there's a connection
between between your cat and milk and
the presidency i've read things like
that
well if you want to be president bad
enough anything would be a sign
yes so cause and effect is one whole
there's one whole domain of logic around
cause and effect there's a whole set of
domains around categories does you know
uh does does the cap belong in the
category of pet or in the category of
you know sex object and you think well
i suppose that's becoming more
politically relevant
but but actually i i actually find it
it'd be fun to uh parse some political
speeches with you because i think that's
they're they're they tend to be empty of
actual object well they are because
they're so good at the second one so the
second value cluster is around rhetoric
so if logic is about being aligned with
the world as it is and and being uh
understanding the forces in the world
rhetoric is aligning with the reader and
with the audience you know in writing
it's the reader but in speaking of
course it's the audience and in video we
call it the audience it's like it's like
connecting it's it's connecting it's
connecting and and it's in and you're
you're working backward from the values
of the reader so if the reader wants to
hear something a good rhetorician will
figure out a way for the reader to hear
that now if i say politician instead of
rhetorician it seems almost synonymous
right i see and the political speech is
primarily designed to excite the desire
to vote and so what i need to do is to
make you believe in my speech that i am
speaking your heart yeah and if i can
speak your heart then then that's good
now the problem with voting is because
you have to get a majority of votes
you have to create the illusion that
you're speaking a majority of hearts
it's almost impossible to actually do
that hence you get the logic and the
more logic you put into the speech the
more likely you're going to alienate so
and as i mean my cat example was a
little bit ridiculous but an example of
you hear this all the time in politics
on both sides of the aisle is
you know how dare my opponents want to
raise taxes the taxes are your money and
how dare my opponents want to cut
benefits the benefits those are your
benefits i say we can do both
i mean you hear that
all the time
you do and basically you know it's like
the the and
when they get away from the pulpit uh
what the thing was actually rather
discouraging about the united states
government right now is even when they
get away from the microphone they don't
give it up right so so so so i always
say the best way to be a convincing
salesperson is to believe it yourself
so they believe that they can they can
they can reduce revenue and increase
spending and nothing bad will and navi i
forgot to talk and they also will talk
about how bad the deficit is right
exactly they'll say those three things
at the same time or even or they'll
retreat to a highly polarized position
but what they what they won't do is what
they won't do is get real so the problem
so we're in the domain of rhetoric we're
not in the domain of logic so
and and so you see these things like the
people that had to make the promise that
i the pledge no new taxes no matter what
it's actually a rhetorical strategy not
a logical strategy it doesn't it's not
it doesn't have to do with the forces in
the world it has to do with aligning
right they're appealing the people
values the taxes are infringing on my
rights my personal property et cetera
now rhetoric is incredibly important
because
if you do not engage the values of your
audience you they will not act in ways
that are constructive for to your
strategic intent so you we shouldn't
think of rhetoric as dishonest um uh
empty logic rhetoric paired with empty
logic is dishonest but logic without
rhetoric is often um uh correct but
ineffective because it's cold it's like
a computer it's like a law it's like a
legal document it's like most of the
textbooks that you're eviscerating right
now with this program
right
not all of them because some of them are
appalling on all three but uh all three
standards so there's logic and there's
rhetoric and then there's the third one
is grammar
so grammar is actually a set of
conventions and when people say i don't
like writing it's often because they had
their nose rubbed in grammar yes and
they really didn't learn anything about
logic and rhetoric and so there was no
power grammar is so if if logic is being
true to the world
and rhetoric is being true to the
audience what grammar is being true to
is the linguistic tradition actually
you're being true to a set of
conventions of the ruling class of your
society yeah the time you're on earth
so
you sound like you're a member of the
ruling class exactly that's what the
grammatical rules are designed to align
you with the language conventions of the
ruling class
and and of course colonial one of the
more offensive things about colonialism
is that it it takes the language of the
ruling class of one country and seeks to
impose it on the language habits of
people in other countries so
and and there's a lot i mean obviously
i've had many people try to get me to
stop saying y'all yo i
and part of that by the way is y'all
is is actually has a rhetorical effect
in in america at least which which is
very disarming and kind of you all it's
kind of like we all we're kind of we're
all in this together and we're not
snooty and we're kind of down to earth
and we drive red pickup trucks and you
know try to get along with people yes
so okay i don't drive a pickup truck oh
well
well then you're probably not an alabama
native i mean i'm thinking we don't want
to offend anyone
well red pickup trucks are not from
louisiana and trust alabama was a
perfectly fine place
you next door neighbors okay
this west coast prejudice stuff will get
out yes you have biases you should visit
alabama i'm actually taking offense now
okay okay you should keep keep working
you should visit alabama
i'm a tree hugger from oregon so i have
my own sort of mossy problems
okay so there's three there's three
there's three then sort of disciplines
and in fact in the roman times and in
the medieval curriculum in the
renaissance curriculum they were called
the trivium
which stands for three things logic
rhetoric and grammar and so for
thousands of years these these three
value systems your ability to cite
things in latin yes makes you part of
the ruling class in my mind that
you've just trumped me you just seem
smarter than you no no no no no the the
ruling class of about the 18th century
okay no it was isaac newton isaac newton
wrote principia in latin right but not
so much writing in latin these days as
it was now the other thing that makes
this comp so that's that's complicated
enough because you say was my writing
logical is my writing rhetorical is my
writing grammatical that's one thing but
then the next thing you find about
language which is so fascinating is if
you start like it's like working from
atoms to molecules to
tissues to organs to organisms
language atomically i mean i guess you
get down to letters we normally start
with words so so words is kind of like
the base place you start with language
and says okay i'm going to learn a bunch
of things about words and you know you
learn about nouns you learn about verbs
you learn about modifiers and
conjunctions and these these help you
kind of the building blocks of language
and then and you use them to write
sentences and one of the things you
discover fairly early on in life is
you can know everything about all the
words and still write bad sentences yes
uh so sentences so this what that means
is there's an emergent property as you
move up a layer in the systems hierarchy
from the word to the sentence a bunch of
properties appear that were not present
at the lower level just like
hydrogens of gas oxygens of gas you put
them together you get water who knew it
was wet yes and heavy yes it's like who
knows right so the emergent properties
so there's stuff that happens at the
sentence level that you would not detect
by just a bag of a bag of words yeah the
same thing happens when you go from
sentences to paragraphs so when you put
sentences together in a paragraph all of
a sudden there's a set of relationships
that that need to be
that the reader is expecting or or
looking to engage with that you you
could write perfect sentences and write
horrible paragraphs right right the last
one is from the paragraph to the essay
that one actually isn't as hard if you
can write good paragraphs you're going
to come pretty close to having most of
the values of the essay but there are
some new things that happen at the essay
level
with introductions and conclusions in
particular that you don't have at the
paragraph level so now you've got a
three by four matrix
so you got three yeah
i inadvertently drew a three by four or
four by three or oh that's fine it's
perfect but you got it right there so
now if you would just draw that this
becomes this becomes an interesting
thing so what i what if you're really
saying
i want to master the college writing
requirement from the point of view of
the product meaning i need to create a
college level product or if i'm in
business i need to create a board level
product or or a i'm trying to create a
marketing requirements document or i'm
trying to create a functional
specification or i'm going to write a a
manual for for teaching people how to
how to use something if you're doing any
technical writing academic writing
business writing marketing communication
writing this is the matrix these 12
squares are the magic squares they they
are the 12 squares where you say in each
one of those squares there's a set of
values or there's a set of attributes
that make for good writing or conversely
would if you if you did not meet those
standards you would make for bad writing
and so all of a sudden it became an
interesting question when you were
teaching ryan to realize you know
not every writer is equally good or
equally bad at all 12 squares
and so it became a the first the first
way we used this was actually as a
diagnostic we said well let's just look
at a large sample of your writing and
let's go through and assess it against
these 12 squares so so if i look at your
vocabulary so are you able to to to
discriminate with words from the point
of view of getting very precise about
the forces you're talking about that's
logic right right decision are you able
to pick words that are apt for the
situation so are they the the right tone
do they have the right nuances that's
rhetoric yeah the word apt was very apt
yeah
yeah
there we go
and and then and then thirdly can you
spell can you spell words correctly and
can you can you hyphenate them correctly
at the end of a line i mean those those
would be that'd be word grammar right
and then you go up to the sentence level
and you say okay now sentence logics
well can you put the subject and the
verb together
do they do that make sense right are we
connecting is is the claim which is
usually in the verb phrase fitting the
topic which is usually in the noun
phrase or the subject and so sentence
logic and then again sentence rhetoric
you can you do short sentences combined
with long sentences can you can you
begin a sentence with a with it with a a
a a a like a adverb like although i'm
thinking this aesthetics it's it's
emotive it's it's i mean it's still the
act appropriate kind of
continues it is
often this is called style yeah and and
you know style maketh the man is so
there's people have their own styles but
readers also expect different styles in
different situations and so they expect
a very curt style when they're looking
at a stop sign or some warning sign yes
and they expect a more elaborate sign
that said please try to slow down as you
approach this intersection might not not
as good and conversely if you're like
proposing marriage like yes wanna it's
probably not the right style so so
therefore you know style of sentences
and then sentence grammar and that you
know subject verb agreement comma
splicing and all the kinds of things
that that stuff which most people that's
kind of the core grammar that most
people kind of associate it is and i
have to say it's probably one of the
least it's one of the most important
squares from the point of view of
superficial creating an impression right
it's a little bit like table manners yes
the truth is table manners do not affect
your ability to feed yourself
but they do people do judge you on your
table manners right they judge you on
your sentence grammar too but it's it is
it's a ruling class i mean it literally
so i've always found it fascinating out
of all the standardized tests the one
that emphasizes grammar the most is the
gmat for business school because they
recognize if you wanna if you wanna you
know they always say like you know dress
for the job you want well this is this
is this exactly
that's exactly what grammar is grammar
is the dressing that you put on your
language so so so being well dressed
doesn't mean you have you could still be
an empty suit but the tie is done very
well you could be grammatically correct
and be completely empty of any meaning
or emotion or anything right many of us
have had teachers of that nature but we
won't go there
so then
you go up to the next what the wonderful
thing by the way obviously both you and
i had at some point in our lives
you get a handful of teachers in your
life that just transform you yeah they
just did and then and then the other
ones don't matter
so okay so so we go the paragraph level
and then the essay levels at the
paragraph level the logic is more about
i'm building an argument about how
things work in the world is it does it
hold together it claims evidence
warrants things like that
this is where the logic starts to really
build it does not now you're really
building a model of the world is what
you're doing with that logic and the
rhetoric has to do with can i take you
through a sense of generalizations and
specifically go back and forth between
examples and going and abstract if i
stay too abstract too long i'll lose you
if i stay too concrete too long you
won't get the idea and paragraph grammar
there's actually very little in
paragraph grammar there's just a few
conventions and then you go to the
highest level which is the essay itself
and at the logic level this is where you
say i have a thesis and then i have
component arguments that support the
thesis how does that all build
uh on the rhetoric side it's i have an
introduction i have a body and i have a
conclusion how does that all flow and
then on the ground it's interesting i
like how you're differentiating between
thesis and introduction yeah a thesis is
like what's the whole point what's the
argument i'm making what do i wanna like
this is what i'm gonna convince you well
introduction is let me gently bring you
into this nice
feeling that so you like me so that you
want to read the rest of it and so you
tee up the introduction is to tee up the
thesis and you it only needs to be as
long as you think it needs to get the
reader or audience from wherever they
are when you think you're going to
encounter them to be prepared to hear
your thesis and so that's the the
journey and introduction means it's
latin it'll lead in so that's that's
kind of what it's for in conclusion
yeah there you go yeah well you know if
you had three years of that and i got to
use it somewhere and then the other back
end of that is conclusion which is so
what conclusion is for the uh when
you're talking about the rhetoric
it's rhetoric right it's the basically
it's the actionability so after i've
proved my thesis to the best of my
ability let's suppose you say okay
jeffrey i grant your thesis but so what
why do i care what should i do so that's
interesting because if you're if you
were all perfect logicians if we were
like computer programs the thesis is
like this is what i'm going to prove and
you know if i'm doing a math proof once
i make the arguments another
mathematician would say oh yeah you're
done you prove it you're done i agree
with you
and by the way no introduction and no
conclusion necessary right right just
just arguments i don't have to say how
wonderful the world would be if
pythagorean theorem was true
and therefore but if i'm trying to emote
something i should conclude and say
wasn't that amazing haven't i yes well
if you're teaching you ha introduction
and conclusion is critical for teaching
right that's why often great programmers
are bad teachers because they just don't
see the need for either the introduction
or the conclusion and then the grammar
stuff is around publishing it's around
the conventions of publishing whatever
so you can kind of see this is a this is
a place where you have this ability to
to
kind of fill in the blanks and you can
assess yourself if you're in a peer
review with other students they can you
can say well let's look at the you know
the teacher can say just look at the box
on sentence style today right
give give sal and jeffrey feedback on
their sentence style today so it was a
way of organizing and the curriculum in
organizing class experiences and
therefore when the teacher reviewed an
essay they didn't have to grade every
box all the time this is very cool their
goal you have me thinking about things
in new ways
that's the object